hello and welcome to this video on to
recap for round seven therefore the Tata
Steel tournament 2016 again a little bit
late but i'm happy to manage in the
first place i couldn't do it yesterday
in an all over the board event and it
took a lot longer than i thought so no
chance to do it right after round let's
get going and i'm starting with own damn
as I tend to do the less interesting
games getting to the more interesting
ones later made a couple of interesting
games okay let's see uh Tomashevsky
adams we got a queen's gambit declined
and nowadays they tend to allow the
exchange variation because a particular
plan also he employed by adams has
gained lots of popularity and this is
this line with nine th five and here i'm
still a little bit puzzled why they
insert h6e don't understand really maybe
i have to invest time one day to
understand why if six is essential to
play anyway the night h5 plan is very
disciplined for black it really is yeah
black gets this long castle sin and in
this position it doesn't have that much
to fear because well the central
breakthrough is why it's most term of
vias idea like f3e form difficult to do
what you also can do can play on the on
the queenside at night a form their
ideas like that then rook see one but it
also takes a long time that position is
quite solid for black and it has been
for a number of years but it only
recently has caught on with the top
level so Tomashevsky is ultimately
preparing for the e4 break
ISIL idea there but black stays very
solid yeah okay Tomashevsky gets you
fall in but black and take take take and
play route 28 yeah and here we see that
blacks pawn structure looks a little bit
loose mayor's ecig spawn and those are a
little bit loose but there's also see
opps i am sorry c5 to worry about for
white it's always under some pressure
and the way it went actually after some
more trades check they agree to it
already yeah i'm not very exciting that
line is super solid for black and
currently um tough to crack also reason
why nowadays if we go back in then we
water the exchange variation was some
plate on the vast majority of games like
10 years ago it was really believed that
black has to suffer a little bit in that
line but nowadays with nie Dage five
things look up and this makes more and
more white players to go for night at
3am and simply don't don't train on d5
okay that was the first game not very
exciting as we said i'm starting with
them less interesting games yeah we have
to give navara kayaking as well and yeah
that was arguably less thrilling even
yeah okay we've got the semi sloth with
quincy to and kayaking goes for this
line with 8 e 5 and yeah over over
breakfast I had a quick look at some
some of the broadcast that was done
yesterday life and young Gustav salt
coined the term there to Berlin nice and
say
yeah to get them get the position
simplified to a draw it's called Berlin
is nowadays and this is what if I've
tends to do why it has a couple of ideas
besides what it's doing there for
example you could argue that isn't that
isn't that an IQ p yesterday is
something like this for example wyd can
do but all in all he's very insolvent to
still hear their IQ p it's not so much
of a weakness black can develop freely
and tends to hold a draw quite
comfortably and this is what white is
doing that quite often yeah trying to
completely blast open the position in
the center and using his extra Tempe I
mean it's not much but we look here why
it has a little bit more in development
and now actually winsted porn however we
see that black gets a very active
position here already here black hair
Scott Brooks active and he will also
activate the Queen and it's very
difficult to do something here with
white and in fact this is the heavily a
theoretical line something like that is
probably known to experts and we've seen
that navara was actually blitzing out
his moves yeah so like a here started to
think okay yeah well white has their
porn but we see that black is very
active he's got ideas like pushing this
and all you know the likelihood of this
I'm getting to a position where black is
getting the material back for some
activity is very high and mikey IM
pressure on d5 on deform and this is
actually funny i black no s 2 points
down but he's so active what are you
doing there a couple of things are going
on um yeah what is why it's supposed to
play if you play some kind of a actually
you have to cover up to I'm sorry yeah
so Knight f3 is want what you did that
is probably the only movie
and now rookie 2e2 looking at f2 okay
and here we go there's lots of lots of
pressure here on f2 now and what navara
now does um I wasn't completely forced
him played rugby one and like this he
gave the Queen now yeah this is this
kind of thing this is a draw it wasn't
necessary to do that he also could have
played a bit differently if we go back
here something like this and d6 also
seems to work but he probably figured
that this some Queen sacrifice is a draw
yeah he black hand can take for example
but after King edge one it's not clear
that it helped him that much maybe after
see black is still still a porn down and
hear things are not clear yeah if you
take t6 rookie one in here in 25 there's
also stuff happening around the black
king but ok he decided to return or give
away the Queen there and it's probably
just the draw the deep on is dangerous
can't we got this this straight d
against G porn after which it really is
a draw something like that is a pretty
clear straightforward fortress yeah
black hands in a way forward to
everything protectors other and why does
just staying yeah some brief excitement
in this game but all in all a draw was
very much predictable after that very
drawers opening in fact this is a very
drawers opening this kind of position
black is yeah giving away a pawn but
it's so active that you would most
likely get to pawn back and then there's
simply not much play left in the
position as it's completely symmetrical
in a way and snow there's no tension in
terms of pawn structure or anything like
that
ok the next game I'm going to check as
ye against Wesley so we had a Spanish
opening here where are my notes here are
the notes and Wesley is going for the
open Spanish the open way that was
discussed earlier in the vent between
geary and kawana and it seems that they
went for heavily theoretical line which
is nowadays played quite often it seems
no an interesting position here with the
bishop now covering the d3 porn and
guaranteed to complex play what white is
often trying to do is to isolate that DS
vporn to put some peas on d4 and then
try to grab it this is also what do I
eat tries in the gay MC puts Bishop here
but we see that it is not so easy to
grab the pawn if he grabs it now then
black and take and take b3 that doesn't
lead to much he tried this but now it
takes takes NC 5 and blackest um yeah
getting lots of activity why I took the
pawn black takes d4 and here we see that
it feels pretty equal yeah the most
surprising about this game actually I
found was that if we look at this black
is supporting its d pawn and should be
ok the most support of surprising thing
was actually for me that they continued
to play this position for ages now it
seems very Jewish but maybe go ahead I
cannot say i don't know but i don't know
i mean of course you can always play on
and see if something or something
materializes but it I mean deeply it is
to move 70
and there was never really anything
going on I mean maybe Wesley so he
intended to make a draw if anybody black
is better corsair because of the pawn
structure but maybe he got kind of
interested in the game again after you
got in this like f5f for that looks like
a little bit of an advantage for black
and it is it is certainly easier for
black to play but still why should hold
and this is what where he cheat at the
end it still looks scary yeah with the
protected passer but white also has
colors are lame so they agree to a draw
here yeah move 70 very long playing that
in that room ending but read that wasn't
there wasn't much going on okay now for
the more interesting games we've got
next game I want to check is Mammadyarov
with white against who you fall and got
a limbs of Indian here where that
transposase to our goes in very very
quickly gather Rogozin seems to be who
you fans main opening for Blackie in
this event against you for and well she
has played it a lot before so it's not
something she specifically put into her
repertoire for the for this tournament
but still it's something that people can
prepare against let's say it seemed she
seems to very reliably going for it yeah
but mom and Jana off goes for here is
somewhat somewhat restrained approach
not a bad one checks to get the knight
to c6 and then place a movie three I
know that this kind of setups with the
bishop inside the chain they sometimes
look a little bit passive but this is
sometimes deceptive because with them
keeping the bishop inside of the chain
and wide in some way also make sure that
this piece is not traded yeah so it will
very often lead to a somewhat slower
start of the game but ultimately it
keeps more pieces on the board then
let's say Bishop g5 and then takes on f6
yeah this is something for example if
you play Bishop g5 here and black plays
h6 what is normally taking as white has
issues with things like that in some
kind of some kind of phone so instead of
going for a position like that with some
simplification you three is probably
yeah a little bit more interesting
long-term because it keeps more pieces
on the board interesting yes sir well
yeah it's it's at least it's a very very
viable alternative castles for black
Queen c2 back so the Queen doesn't do
much anymore an a4 it was just put there
to drive the night to c6 Bishop 36 and
now this this is one of blacks ideas in
this opening to get in the movie 65 that
kind of structure that we get now after
yeah after this and point one when does
he play it the white plays defy that
kind of structure is well known and is
believed to be a little bit a little bit
better for wide username in fact we
found had various opportunities to
capture on d4 that would have been also
a viable choice something like that that
leads to a position that could easily
happen from a Queens gambit except that
she is probably a tempo down if i'm not
mistaken even though i'm not quite sure
took two moves to go to d6 you 65 takes
to move now she's the tempo down so
keeps the tension and goes for this
position with d5 yeah why is this a
little bit better for white space so
often there the answer
White has a little bit more space and
potentially a black can have trouble
with the CFO or white having a piece
coming to c5 we see that in the game
will you find got that Bishop traded and
now covered c7 so this kind of position
always has to be a little bit of
something for white because it's not
clear what flex ideas black it's mostly
just sitting them and cannot do much of
course there might be people saying it
doesn't write have a bad bishop you're
looking at all those pawns yeah you know
this is not really the case because
white has more space and if you have
more space this consideration is not
that relevant anymore especially because
I'm usually the bishop that is looking
at its own pawns tends to improve
automatically over time because the side
with less space tries to break out of
his or in this case her position um and
then the bishop improves automatically
for example if black and sometimes plays
the move c6 year to make sure that the
d5 be five points are gone of the board
that the bishop automatically gets
better so there's not much to worry
about them yeah in fact we had a further
development of the game at Queen's
traded and white got that piece to c5
and it looks nice for white but it's
still not clear how is going to do
something concrete yeah who'd you find
defended this this is nicely it's
passive but it's very solid and now she
got in c6 so what is happening here is
she equalizing this why took took here
took a five and we get to the critical
position this is the critical position
here she should have played the move
Bishop to e8 just retreating the bishop
and keeping this pressure on
in fact right next move you can take the
pawn back and equalize completely for
example something like yeah what is why
it's supposed to do yeah let's say you
look at the a4 pawn yeah then Luke a8 is
coming night moves and it's totally
equal or what can y tu if you go here
then blackish is taking its it's just
the problem is this is not difficult to
see that this is equal the thing is she
immediately took here and this has a big
big drawback yeah Luke be 8th route 93
of course you cannot take here this lose
everything immediately so Knight takes
c3 and now the move Bishop g4 maybe she
didn't see that move very likely yeah
now it's it's really awkward the rook is
attacked if you take here check 96 guess
what I supposed to play f5 is happening
in the game she go route c7 then night a
six and the rook is overloaded yeah she
had to go at five and now after takes
takes takes takes check gerroff took
here and at the end gets a completely
winning endgame sg5 it's not going to be
a check yeah cannot be held in the long
run here to change was taken check idea
who you found resigned losing the first
game here her first game in that event
and it was really unfortunate in a way
because she made exactly one mistake in
the game and that happened to be the
decisive one if you go Bishop e8 black
gets the pawn back and just gets the
draw that she probably deserved you too
careful defense up to
point but a single mistake can cost the
game this is the often the big issue and
chance yeah you play perfectly ok game
and then just one mistake sports sports
the whole day in a way unlike in other
sports like tennis or Sawyer you can
play complete complete yeah complete
crap let's say and then all of a sudden
you flick the switch and prove prove
your play less unforced errors and other
son become back at stage and the player
who's down like one or two sets can can
win the game store and chest when one
mistake and you're done so that was
Mammadyarov with your fun let's have a
look at the dutch duo we've got van vini
with white against onigiri they had a
sloth defense and when really is going
for the slowest laugh as they all do
nowadays and give you plays Bishop g4
yeah black has a choice that is six we
have seen in this tournament already on
also Bishop f5 all those moves on okay
in the Bishop g4 line why it tends to go
for this kind of things with G form and
this leads to interesting play white has
got more space like this on the King
side and tries to arrest the bishop
however we have to look at one
particular thing here Black is taking on
c4 now Nancy for h 52 595 we have to
look at one particular thing one thing
that is often underestimate it is that
white is running some risk with this
kind of position because it is not clear
where whites king is going to be for
black it's pretty easy to say black will
cancel short and will be reasonably safe
near the bishop on g6 is covering age
five and it's very little what can do to
get at to get to
on black skin quickly so white has some
issues with his King long term he has to
be quite circumspect them and we see
that in a couple of more cm got black
coming in with e5 yeah white cannot win
a pawn if he does so black it gives
country is seven for example and white
absolutely cannot play stuff like that
yeah here he will just get ya under
heavy fire stuff like this check it's
not going to end well just a sample line
with some cooperative play but white
cannot take on e5 what he did is okay it
just said as I said how is why its King
ever going to be safe he cannot cancel
long anymore and canceling short is what
it did but don't underestimate that this
King has no porn shield yeah those pawns
are far advanced yeah c5 now by vent
Valley and a blacks play and this is
what I think if you give this to a
computer by the way it gives 000 we have
equal play that might be true but it is
still difficult to play for white in the
long run because you always have to
worry that your King would end up in
some trouble just imagine in some
situation not like he ever imagined
we've got some pieces training and the
black Queen enters on g4 or something
and then you you lose h4 and your king
is wide open this is the problem so
blacks plenty is pretty simple yeah
trade some pieces not all of them keep
Queens on and open up the position and
why it has to be careful not get to get
into some kind of direct trouble on the
king and let's see what happened in the
game doing is opening it up with b6 it's
constrained it and 95 and now II for ya
blacks idea
night here night here and made in idea
world takes and we see how it opens up
and now black has ideas yeah the night
can come in somewhere and you don't know
really what right is going to do he's
got that got that we king and in this
position um stockfish wants to play 92
and claim some about equal play I
actually think that after 95 let's say
Bishop takes root kings I still rather
be black because black is more
comfortable still and the king is weak
this is weaker than b6 where this is
better than the game yeah we see in the
game when really goes here and we have
something similar actually happening but
now he goes to e2 and loses time in the
process so Black now has a position
comparable to the one before but with
extra moves and now the night
immediately sings in 2d three what a
good night yeah and what is white doing
him well he just sits on his weaknesses
and that point also got lost and now we
see what I was talking about the Queen
sometimes can just enter and now why
this just losing material look at three
using the pin upon second porn
and the third point yeah so at the end a
pretty clear win for Geary and you know
I think this is a risky position for
what long-term even though even though
computers think it's okay but you know
you have to deal with this that the king
is weak and this kind of Yan on solid
play is getting you in the long run
especially if you use as much time as
when really does him yeah you see like
here to move 20 was down to 15 minutes
and playing this kind of position with
the wii king is no fun anyway and
especially not if you are if you are
down long time okay let's go to the next
game yeah it's Kara wanna ding we run
had to pull this game up from the
library yeah so what do we get here we
have a spanish and we have no belinea
this is a think is that the Berlin free
tournament maybe we got one like in the
first round or so but it's not when you
see more of the ocm and typically of
leading to more interesting play yeah 63
by kawada one of the main lights rupee
one is the other one but III is one of
another way to avoid them the marshal
nowadays and to toe introduce some
interesting ideas and so a three and
black goes for a quick c5 and Bishop to
e6 an interesting line yeah White has a
couple of ideas 95 is some the most
frequent the sea move but koala comes
with a new idea place nine to h4
interesting clear intentions in light
wants to go to f5 and two versions of
that sometimes you can directly go there
in some cases white might play Queen a
three and then put the night on f5 the
first thing to check is what happens
after nine takes you for this typical
technical idea has to be checked in this
case however it is clearly too risky
um wyd can get an idea for sure edge for
ticks ticks and Queen h5 this kind of
position here is much too scary for
black yeah also take note that caruana
has blitzed all this tonight h4 so it I
mean besides the fact that it's pretty
clear that night XD force not good
having this you are doing this against
someone who has prepared the ideas and
particularly questionable um yeah ding
now goes with c4 after some thought and
that move is of course not pointless at
all it blocks the bishop however it
seems to be risky this Bishop I mean it
it seems to seems to be risky somewhat
the reason is that white now went night
f5 quite clearly that was the idea takes
you cannot keep that takes and now
castles and the thing is that after tix
and Bishop g5 and black is now sitting
in a position where he has to reckon
with Bishop takes f6 and night coming to
d5 where it will be excellently placed
long-term this happened in the game the
night coming 25 even though under
somewhat more favorable circumstances as
now black doesn't have a bishop by the
night to challenge the white piece on d5
in any case why this better here now the
pawn on c4 is weak a six is weak d6 this
week so there are some weaknesses to
play against um and yeah white only has
the somewhat of a 5.8 so I have also
limiting black and some way
so black tries to get rid of that night
yeah he sacrifices the poor for doing
that and activates yeah White's position
is clearly better but winning it is
another matter after before g5 and
queens e6 we see that black has a decent
Center and some play on the C file it's
not clear on that then what um has a win
here the way it went yeah check that the
way it went um black was active pretty
active and fast for wanting a little bit
yeah we also have to take him out it's a
pawn but it's not yet a very dangerous
porn and b5 is not that quick so a
couple of moves later we come to a
critical situation yeah Black has gone
to play there yeah and here now here
there were one or two moments where ding
could have played could've played batter
and here Queen d7 was a lot stronger
than what he played he played rock c6
after Queen d7 I think blacks drawing
chances are pretty good this is a tech
this is attacked and a5 is under fire so
it's not quite clear what why should do
now if you move screen be one for
example black just plays a wedding moven
asked white what he's doing it's very
difficult to improve here if you move
this away and
this gets lost yeah computers just gives
equal completely equal this was played
however the Queen takes a five groups
III was was tough on Brooks III was
tougher but again that was not played
it's still it's questionable if blacking
out but it's somewhat somewhat tougher
defense yeah you still have to deal with
that weakness here yeah after this
however oops keep pressing that after
this however it seems that black is just
lost him his two points down on one
flank and we don't see any particular
counterplay happening okay even the rook
endgame is pretty easy win chan white
can just advance his choice and does it
have to check be varied much say no this
is an important motif now the King can
enter and is shielded by its own porn
from checks from the back chang no this
was also possible I know we see that
ending Jan I already played for a long
time I didn't see that I stopped a
couple of most earlier when I prepared
prepared the game so very important win
vaca wanna yeah for the standings we had
them before the round kawana and ding on
plus two so caruana moves up to plus
three very strong score and he mr. win
against against giri in an earlier game
so it could have been even better
so let's look at the the final game in
this video yeah final game to check is
alien of cards and here we go Carlton is
some now on some kind of a small role
he's got two wins in a row and let's see
what he can do with black against the
very solid alien of Queens gambit nope
catalan catalan is sown area knows main
opening them and Carlton is going to
Bishop b4 check this is so very popular
nowadays and is a very good middle of
the road approach that black can try if
he wants to play I mean not like trying
to simplify everything down to a draw if
he wants some kind of fight but without
risking anything extraordinary with
which black can also do by lets in
snatching the porn and playing be five
or something like that which is probably
kind of kind of unsound gem but yeah
what black is doing with Bishop before
is going for a game let's say and see
what happens Bishop t2 and backyard this
flicking this in as I mentioned in an
earlier video for the talasea coverage
is the idea of that check to get the
bishop on that D 2 square it's not so
well placed there wyd quite often once
to fianchetto it and in some cases also
that BD two can be useful so what that
means is that here in this kind of
position white yea rather would have the
bishop on c1 to play Quincy to be three
he goes for twin c2 and nightly fauna by
carlson this is already slightly offbeat
ya see six is the farm walk normal move
but still this has been played it's not
a new position see 693 and now Thousand
doors for interesting move in g5 this is
not a new move where it has been played
back in the nineteen sixty three World
Championship match between Tigran
Petrosian at Botvinnik yeah what Vinick
was a huge fan of the Stonewall Dutch
and therefore you continued with their
five Petrosian actually decided to go to
see one but you don't think is a bad
idea it doesn't look so aggressive but
the bishop is bad I won't be too then
somewhere only three and what Vinick
played with f5 then and they got an
interesting position this is what i
meant with an approach for black to get
a game going and to play something
interesting without risking too much
this is an interesting kind of position
where long-term you will have conflict
on the Kings side but you're not taking
some yeah irresponsible risk let's say
by snatching a porn and exposing
yourself um I enough went to e3 however
and now very interesting play by cars of
course you can play a five and it would
fit into the position but he played 926
and this is quite an interesting idea
yeah black is attacking the c-4 porn and
asks white what is going to do about it
if white now takes a very simple
approach and takes on d5 then after it
takes I think black is perfectly fine
the bishop on g2 is yeah it's Blanchard
near against this g5 c6 structure and
black still has ideas to play later
advanced with the f porn the night on d6
also is nicely positioned to faciliate a
possible Bishop to f5 or Knight to f5 if
that square is controlled so alien of b3
is logically black now could have taken
on c4 however this is a risky decision
clearly is yeah y term has a number of
ideas even just I mean you can also what
I'm trying to say is he does not need to
take on c4
but can play like a centralizing move
it's difficult to expose yourself on the
Kings side and then open up the center
like that even the simple capture like
this this and now later just a key for
it will be difficult for black to handle
you want the center closed and causing
those 495 this is a banner McGrath
engine didn't and taking an idea is here
for black simply to take the bishop grab
the bishop pair white cannot really
remove the bishop if he moves it again
this is happening and I think you're
hard pressed to to play this position
it's still not simple in a way that
black has one upon but it's also not
very convincing blacks position is
exposed but it's a big center pond so I
understand what lem of debt he played g4
interesting move there's this and now
this next movement the following play by
Kansas is very nice i like the whole
game a lot actually yeah black could
have played yeah normal move I'm not
quite sure what that would be because
cars movers is just a lot stronger than
any other move um gannett a plan or what
we should have six or so yeah then white
will come with a form and open up the
center and well hmm yeah what is playing
is just so much strong in please be five
directly attacking white sea for porn
and getting for play here and the big
thing is you get this idea in also that
can dislodge the White Knight and makes
plain you for much more difficult there
isn't that a pawn sacrifice it is but
black has very nice compensation here
for example um simple moves let's say
like Queen B 6 are quite okay yeah now
like sa4 and black develops rook c8 he's
got counter play on the weekend the
weekend squares and if
not going to happen yeah note that this
bishop sometimes has a square ok you
have to cover chief I but you know black
is doing things on the queenside and
preventing afore in the center so his
weakened King side doesn't really is so
much of a factor and note that he has
the two bishops which is good long-term
good long-term play yeah Elian loft
didn't want to do that he wanted to do
something in the center efore yeah
blasting things open yeah and now we see
Collins a day he goes before he also
could have taken on c4 this is not a
ridiculous decision but it's also pretty
well it's not so consistent yeah you
wanted to dislodge that night with
before I now you your grab material here
for example after you five Knight b6 and
let's say nitey form why does getting
pieces near the black king I don't like
this so much I think what he was playing
is it's just it's just wrong I mean this
is some typical kind of computer
suggestion but this is a more human move
because now what is they're not going to
do you have to go to some awkward spot
or sacrifice it and alien off decided to
go for it yeah he sacrificed the piece
which is interesting very interesting
move he could have of course just gone
to a form that was possible after which
black is probably going to take and
after recapture let's say politics here
is going see 5 or possibly five one of
the two moves I'm not quite sure what's
better but let's say after you five this
is an interesting choice and now one
goes d5 l'd saying look how bad this
Bishop is it really just looking at his
own pawns and black has excellent play
on the dark squares the whole position
is super complicated and certainly
exactly what Carlton wanted from this
game yeah I think I leonov's decision is
is very brave yeah he just sacrifices to
peace and it is an interesting position
we have to be perfectly honest and
looking for lupia takes now important
not going anywhere else but be eight if
black let's say goes to f6 then c7 is a
problem after Queen takes Knight e5
there's immediate threats so not very
advisable and IPA this better it looks a
bit wacky undeveloped but it looks at
that we important c6 pawn and this is
something that white probably wants to
keep that pawn this is why you went
queen to you for yeah I computer suggest
something like this but after 96 I think
let's say 95 we should be fine Bishop
p.m. Andrew p8 um gap leg is in good
shape we take something like this if we
do a quick count seven points against
four so it's a fair compensation
justjust if we just do counting but
don't forget that whites king is
probably arguably even less safe than
blacks king and blacks bishops
especially that bishop here will be who
be quite strong yeah this was played and
cons of course going to goes for f5
activating activating everything here
yeah Kings takes yeah and now Elian of
course Queen d5 and it really seems like
after that I mean there's no clear
improvement but after that night a six
it becomes clear that this piece
sacrifice was interesting but ultimately
not totally sufficient as the night has
that blockading quality none of the sea
porn is not running away and you can
pressurize the d5 pawn
now c7 nice little short has cards an
overlook this no he didn't the thing is
that after knight takes Bishop takes
Knight takes the material situation has
has changed now black has two bishops
against rook and pawn but this is even
more favorable than the piece for pawns
because the bishops will be super strong
and we see what happens first bishop to
be formed and bishop to be seven and
this is a fantastic diagonal for this
piece early enough tried to break the
kingside structure open with h4 but we
see black's pieces getting activated
very quickly the night is coming to to
d5 ultimately yeah and white has a check
there he actually sorry I didn't know I
enough already resigned he had looked at
the gamer Liam and I thought that he
still gave the check on age 6 yeah he
resigned to y'all ready there is nothing
nothing to do here against black
attacking and promoting the e porn has
routed to coming also yeah what can give
a check for exam and I thought that he
actually did that but didn't seem to be
yeah here you're out of moves at the
rook has no squares for example if white
is trying to stop the porn there is
routed to and hear that pawn will
promote yeah this was I think an
excellent game by by Carlton he short
form somewhat got an idea in the opening
here with his g5 and then came up with
96 setting alien off new problems and
with night f5 again that was a very
tough decision now a while and do you
want to move the bishop again and give
up the deep one who probably not but
that leads to this kind of structure
which is very difficult to play so he
managed to get to post lots of difficult
difficult problems for the
opponent out of a very classical and not
very exciting at first looking opening
so very nice player by the world
champion who's got the third win in a
row so he's really on fire now and Isco
leading the event together with Caruana
both on plus three now okay i hope you
enjoyed the coverage here around seven
of the Tata Steel event I hope to do the
road aight video a little bit earlier
and then this one but yeah i'm a bit
busy nowadays ok well thanks for
watching